the most important story tonight jeff is
how will tooky toussaint handle his
assignment in game two coming off a
short outing against colorado at coors
field so here's josh bell pick your
poison here left-handed batter the
switch hitter 261 this side of the plate
that ball ripped
freeman
nats will get a run with thomas coming
home so when he runs in the first to be
unearned because of the errand josh bell
gets rbi number 77.
lots of traffic and more here in the
first inning
and kibum hits one high in the air
toward left that's going to be playable
for rosario at the edge of the track and
that will retire the side
31 years old 6-4-2-50 last start
september third against guess who the
mets
one on
one out that one behind freeman
and solaire does not advance
well i think we know what that was all
about
lance park still looked into the
washington dugout did not issue any
warnings
juan soto hit in the ninth inning last
night was not too pleased about it
1-0 pitch
and he got him
so freeman's hit by a pitch
kind of figured that was going to come
now the umpires are going to convene
i mean it was as plain as day he threw
behind him with the first one you knew
the second one had a pretty good chance
of hitting the target
and nolan has been ejected from the game
they protect soto but they lose their
pitcher
the umpires have the latitude
to read intent
and they think he totally intended to
hit that freddie martinez wants to run
out there so bad right now freddie
freeman and juan soto were talking over
their respective hit by pitches soto
last night freeman today and then after
freeman was called out at second base he
made his way over to the nationals
dugout to talk with davey martinez sure
like anything they're just talking about
the situation but i guarantee freddie
wasn't happy about that first pitch
raves finally got him out back in the
first inning a 1-4-3 ground out
2-2 on the way
check swing and the dirt they appeal
strike three and arnold lobs down to
first base just to make it official and
a one two three inning for tukey that's
a way to get back in line
a couple of strikeouts in the inning
sits them down in order we head to the
bottom of the third inning one nothing
washington
bell 281 going way way back
breaking ball josh bell waiting for it
right center
c
u
later two nothing gnats
on bell's
team leading
25th of the year do it josh bell
4 31.
popped him up can anybody catch up to it
solaire chugging in he slides and it's
freddie freeman who makes the play
freddie freeman with his back to the
infield makes the grab on an
over-the-shoulder catch wow
how about this opponents have used a
defensive shift against adam duvall 73
percent of his played appearances this
season
3-2 pitch
swung on it hit hard high in the air
back towards the wall this one is out of
the ballpark
that's how you beat the ship right there
homer number 33 for adam duvall that
ties a career high and it puts the
braves on the board it's now a 2-1
washington lead here in the fourth
what a year he's having
he's having a great year just the time
he's playing in a braves union
on the ground riley nice play lost his
footing but through a strike anyway
that's a beautiful play one out yeah
nice like you said lost his footing but
got up and threw a strike across which
he had to to get him in time the ball
kind of stayed down on him too
eddie rosario payoff pitch on the way
swung on golf to right field heads up in
the chop house tie game
home run rosario
his ninth of the year in his 52nd rbi
it's two to two another player acquired
at the trade deadline doing big things
for the braves
that's a winner
now rodriguez will try to continue that
with thomas escobar and soto for
washington the pitch is right back where
it came from oh nice scoop by ozzy in
the shift the mound might have helped
the brave second baseman there yeah good
positioning and a big first out
[Music]
soto has struggled tonight he's hit two
soft ground balls and then struck out on
a curve in the dirt here's the wind in
the pitch
swinging a long drive right center field
way back goes this one
going going and long long gone
about 10 rows deep into the seats over
the big wall in right center field
juan soto with homer number 25
gives the nationals the lead back three
to two and doesn't that feel oh so good
after taking a fastball in the ribs in
the ninth inning last night juan soto
put that one into orbit to put the
nationals back in front
the one-two
bell pops it to left
rosario who hit a homer earlier makes
the catch 3-2 washington time for the
stretch
got him looking 96.
and this one the other way from riley
soto has it measured
huge second out
upstairs for the strikeout nice
austin both goes into a second inning
wanderswero takes care of the end of the
seventh and then that's because of the
bullpen hanging tough and so does homer
a lead into the eighth
lefty lefty for luis garcia
he does
right field hernandez scores garcia
heading for second
and the lefty lefty matcha pays off for
the nets
luis with rbi number nine and a two run
lead in the eighth that's a big knock
12th double the season
it's a big old hanger right there that
pitch did absolutely nothing and he took
advantage of it it's up to cal finnegan
now to nail this thing down lefties
haven't done much with him
bang 96 up and in
one out see that's my favorite kyle
finnegan right there when he just goes
after you at the heater
[Music]
swing and a tip and a strikeout two down
that's what i'm talking about
freeman lashes one to left but yadiel is
there
and the gnats will win it four
two
on a brilliant night for the bullpen i
might add
yeah the bullpen was money we saw some
far taters
kyle finnegan was fantastic right there
getting a huge out freddy freeman a nice
curly w for the gnats in atlanta tonight
you